[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au soir tout le
monde
patron je descend vite j'ai l'impression
qu'il se passe des choses bizarres dans
la roulotte tu crois oui
mon flair me le dise allons voir cela de
plus près mon le cheval airs pop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop
ou sac tu les a trouvés qui veut régner
dans la paroisse quand on échoue vous
avez froid alors je les ai ramenés au le
show oh je savais bien qu'il se passait
des choses anormales
attendait un peu mais le gaillard tient
notre nounours tu n'as pas l'air de très
bonne humeur ce soir
chrome os en l'air de très bonne humeur
je suis d'excellente humeur oui mais
dans une roulotte propres il n'y a pas
d'arrêt y est aussi je vais aider ces
enfants à mettre super stion
[Applaudissements]
d'opi mais ce sont vos âmes et nous
[Musique]
déjà rendu au plus tôt au char a mis ces
araignées sont inoffensives alors qu
elle me doit nous donne moi ton bonnet
non jeu car dans mon malheur
je crois qu'il me manque in wa
mulumba
ou etl
la cie retourner au secours au secours
qu'aucune darrieux alors chers amis vos
nerfs vous lâche t malin elle est partie
pour une petite araignée ou le sag et je
la sens dans mon dos descend ça pour
me donne le ton à temps non mais pas
comme ça je n'étais pas bien à mina
je domaine des pépites à ma jolie
[Musique]
ouf tu as un revenu de l'histoire vous
vous effrayer pour peu des choses chères
nounours cher dada j'aimerais beaucoup
voir avec une araignée sur les naseaux
ce sont deux charmantes bestioles est
elle fondée si jerry dessin avec leur
fille bêtise des toiles de toiles
d'araignées de nioc poussière ballon en
dortoir vite mon petits cornichons ni
demain remet ses araignées en liberté
donnez nous ne le dira
brad thomas
est de bohain
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
seul pétrole
alors nounours avec qui te battu avec
deux soirées du patron tu as peur des
araignées oui potter en tout cas tu n'en
as pas sur toi séverin or trop mieux
partons vite tout de même bonne nuit les
petits
allez vite vous coucher est fait pour
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]